hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast t2 sepsis solution
diagnostic value and practical
application in real world Hospital
presented by dr. Patricia Munoz from the
division of clinical microbiology and
infectious diseases at the hospital
General University Gregorio
Madame young in Madrid Spain I'm Suzy
Valdez of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes and
sponsored by t2 bio systems
t2 bio systems is developing innovative
diagnostic products aimed at lowering
mortality rates improving patient
outcomes and reducing the cost of health
care by helping medical professionals
make targeted treatment decisions
earlier with two fda-cleared products
targeting sepsis and arrangement of
additional products and development t2
bio systems is an emerging leader in the
field of in vitro diagnostics before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type those questions into the box that
appear on the screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon in the lower right if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing educational
credits please click on the button at
the lower left corner and follow the
process for obtaining your credits I now
like to introduce the speaker dr.
Patricia Munoz dr. Munoz studied
medicine at the University complete
onset of Madrid and did her residents in
the hospital clinic Santo Carlos of
Madrid where she completed several
research and clinical fellowships under
the mentorship
of professor Emilio Botha she did the
fellowship in infectious diseases at the
hospital in general Gregorio marañón
where she was accepted first as a
research fellow and layer on the staff
at present dr. Munoz is a professor of
medicine in clinical microbiology at the
cupola tents a University of Madrid and
is the head of the infectious disease
section at the division of clinical
microbiology and infectious diseases at
the hospital general University Gregorio
marañón please join me in welcoming dr.
Patricia Minos welcome dr. Munoz hello
everybody this is Patricia communauté
from Madrid in Spain and I have the
pleasure to share with you our
experience with the Candida t2 here you
have my disclosures let's begin with a
brief introduction if you are hearing
this webinar you are positively aware of
importance of Candida infections Candida
infections actually account for
approximately 6% of nosocomial
infections and unfortunately a still
carries a high mortality rate in certain
populations may even reach 40% we are
perfectly aware of the importance of
controlling the source and of providing
rapid effective antifungals as you can
see in the slide if you are not able to
do both things to provide treatment in
the first 24 hours and to control the
source the mortality of your patients
will be extremely high some years ago
this paper you can see in the slide also
demonstrated that even slight delays in
starting effective antifungal had a
great impact
Metallica the difference between
startled antifungal on day one with 25%
mortality and day two with 35 or even 40
something mortality you studied it later
is very impressive so why do we have all
these problems for treating patients
with candidiasis it is because the
diagnostic methods we have are not
perfect at all we have been using for
years clinical scores to identify
patients in which the probability of
candidiasis is high as high as to
deserve empiric treatment and we have
been using the Ostrovsky scores the
candida score the colonization index etc
but as you can see in the slide
although the negative predictive value
for this course is good the positive
predictive value is extremely low thus
making a street unnecessarily hundreds
and hundreds of patients of course we
still rely on blood cultures but blood
cultures have poor sensitivity less than
50% in most studies
fortunately new methods not based on
culture appear and we have been using
for years now they pitted occlusion
however the beta glucan test may have
false positives they were 35% in our
recent study and also false negatives in
certain patients and infections so at
the end of the day we have difficulties
for identifying who are the patients at
risk of Candida infection the patients
at risk of poor outcome and in patients
with demonstrated candidiasis who are
the patients at risk of complicated
disease which is the result of all these
problems that physicians nowadays tend
to use broad and prickle
Friedman and usually maintain therapy
for proven infections probably for very
long periods of time so in summary we
rely on blood cultures with the limit of
detection of less than one colony
forming unit per ml and low sensitivity
we have maldita but Molotov will help us
in identifying the identity of our gist
but needs a positive culture and we have
already spoken about the problems with
Italy glucan so some years ago tea to
Emma for Canada detection appear and it
was a great breakthrough as you know it
is based on the Nano diagnosis of viable
candidate microorganisms it detects the
most five common Candida species it is
going to be improved and detect more
species and more importantly it detects
the candida in whole blood you don't
need to wait for the positivity of a
culture so with her fully automated
methodology you will have your result in
three to five hours this was the most
important paper that make all our heads
heads turn to the t2 magnetic resonance
assay it was published some years ago in
CIB it included more than one thousand
patients with positive blood cultures
but only for convenience in this study
and 250 Speight blood culture bottles
and controls the results were extremely
good sensitivity higher than 90 percent
specificity always 100% so we decided to
do two studies the first one is a study
on patients with Candida Miam and the
second one is a study on patients who
married empiric anti
so let's begin with the first one the
candy Demian study once you have candy
be Mia in one of your patients you have
to differentiate patients with
complicated Candida meal from the
patients with uncomplicated Kundalini as
you know patients with Candida Mia may
have subject metastases may have poor
prognosis or other relatively benign
disease and early differentiation
between those two settings is usually
based on blood cultures and we have
already mentioned that blood cultures
have a load of let's say false negative
results so if you have a patient with
persistent positive blood cultures of
course you are in front of a complicated
condominium but if your patient does not
have persistent not conscious you still
may have a complicated disease so what
does the guidelines recommend guidelines
recommend to perform follow-up blood
cultures with a strong recommendation of
the base or low quality evidence and for
most patients with positive blood
cultures you will have to do aft Alma
lot of Tomas Copic evaluation
echocardiogram and you will decide the
length of treatment according to the
positivity of blood cultures and to the
findings on those complementary tests so
starting with this situation that can
give emia may or may not be associated
with septic metastasis we decided to
start our study with a objective of
assessing the usefulness of follow-up t2
in comparison to blood cultures and beta
glucan to early differentiate patients
with complicated or uncomplicated
Kundalini
we perform a prospective multicentric
study in three hospitals in Madrid Spain
patients included were all adults with
can Davinia recruited from January to
June 2017 as soon as we receive the
first positive blood culture with
Candida in next blood culture we obtain
blood samples on days serum two four
seven and for him to perform he to blood
cultures and beta glucan simultaneously
until the pills were negative for
predicting the diagnostic performance of
the different tests we divided the
results or we analyzed the results at
two different times he early period
results obtained from day three to five
and late period results obtained beyond
day five what was our definition of
complicated convenient for our study we
classify a convenience complicated when
the episodes involve metastatic lesions
in other power grams or when the patient
died during the follow-up period which
was one month so very a strict
definition here you have the recruitment
we recruited patients in hospital doctor
dr. brain Gregorio marañón and Ramona
kaha initially we recruited 44 other
patients however 14 had to be excluded
six because they died in the first today
five didn't sign the informed consent
and in three cases we got invalid t2
results
so finally we could analyze 30 patients
with Candida Nia half of the patients
were made and
was 66 years old here you have the first
herself when you analyzed your
convenience 70% will fulfill our
criteria of uncomplicated condominium
and the remaining 30% did have
metastases or died during the follow-up
and they were thus classified as
complicated here you have the
epidemiological characteristics of both
populations uncomplicated in blue
uncomplicated in red as you can see the
population is very normal similar to
what you may found in most tertiary
hospitals half of the population were
male most common underlying disease were
malignancies diabetes cardiovascular
problems the mchavez core was non fatal
in approximately half of the patients
the charge and comorbidity index was
between 3 and 4 and the risk factor for
Candida mia were also the usual ones
central venous catheter plants on
nutrition previous surgery or
corticosteroids therapy and as you can
see there were no clear differences
between both populations that would
allow you to identify who is at risk of
having a complicated condominium when we
move to the clinical characteristics of
the patients again no difference in
blood stream source most of them were
catheter related but they were also
abdominal or urinary tract and lenience
no difference in species our becomes
perhaps losses and glabrata
were the more common and they are the
more common in our country patients with
complicated Cal edenia get present with
more severe disease there was no
difference regarding
source control which was pretty high in
both arms of the study around 7080
percent
patience have received a mean of two
days of antifungal therapy before
recruitment and the hospital mortality
was clearly higher in patients with
complicated condominium or the
difference did not reach statistical
significance but it was five percent
versus thirty three percent and look at
here the length of therapy was clearly
longer for patients with complicated Cal
edenia 39 days versus 18 let me just
start with a clinical example here we
have a man of 60 years old with Tong
carcinoma in 2004 and afterwards a
supraglottic Escobar cell carcinoma he
underwent surgery chemotherapy he needed
a central venous catheter and underwent
complete remission however on November
2016 developed his first local
recurrence requiring surgery and the
post-operative course was complicated
with catheter related Candida Mia due to
Kalia tropicalis it required the removal
of the portico and 14 days of her
however some months later a couple of
months later in January he developed
again recurring Canady Miam we moved to
a kind of calming treatment even though
the strain was susceptible and performed
follow-up blood cultures and they came
negative however we were very aware of
the high risk of and the vascular
infection when you have late recurrence
of convinient based on our previous
experience as you can see patients who
recur after in the first two or three
months usually have endocarditis or
septic thrombophlebitis
so we perform an echocardiogram and the
patient proved to have an infective
endocarditis affecting the right heart
that course people in the field I have
summarized for you the results of the
blood cultures in red
of t2 in bloom half embittered
development in green as you can see
blood cultures were positive then
negative when we started treatment and
again positive however t2 in blue was
positive all time alone even after
surgery after surgery blood cultures
were in middle negative however the t2
was positive for one more week
and this was because the patient was
proven to have pulmonary metastasis of
the infectious endocarditis so let me
show you in the same type of figure our
uncomplicated convenience I'm not going
to describe every single patient for you
you have them summarized in the slides
however I want you to just to look at
the Blues we are talking about
uncomplicated candy demyans you see that
very commonly the beta glucan at the
bottom remains positive none from time
to time you have positive blood cultures
here you have more patients but you can
see that we have very few blues here
impatient at the bottom here you have
one room but this was because the
catheter haven't been withdrawn the
moment the catheter was withdrawn in
this uncomplicated convenient it who
became negative but the beta glucan as
you can see remain positive here you
have more uncomplicated candy demons and
they were only positive 2 T 2 in
patients in which the the source had not
been properly control let's move now to
complicate academia as you can see here
all the patients have blue in all the
cases the T 2 was positive we have one
candidate prognosis with intra-abdominal
and ocular metastases we have one
candidate from phlebitis with ocular
meatus
we have one endocarditis with lung
metastases and here another opener
infection the young patients with
complicated Candida Mia's and in all the
cases you have the t2 that was positive
in summary when we analyzed all the
patients together at least one positive
surveillance test was obtained in 33% of
their blood cultures we took but in
almost 60% of the teachers and look at
this only half of the patients with a
positivity - had a positive concomitant
blood culture when we divided our
samples in early samples and late
samples you can see that blood cultures
were positive during the first five days
in 30 percent of our patients keep - in
half of them and practically all the
patients had a positive beta development
so it wasn't really of help for an early
differentiation of these two populations
when we move beyond the first week blood
cultures remain positive only two
patients 6.7% but key - in 23% and we
terrific new con is still positive in
practically 65 percent of the patients
so when we analyzed both populations and
complicated and complicated patients as
you can see the only test that provide a
significant difference between them was
positive t2 that was positive in only
23% of the uncomplicated patients
packing 100% of the complicated patients
regarding late samples and
Tito was the only one providing
significant difference which was the
sensitivity specificity positive
predictive value and negative predictive
value of the three test blood cultures t
tomb and beta glucan for detecting
complicated candy demons you can see
them in their slide with the intervals
of confidence and as you can see t -
both in the early and late period were
the ones providing best results we then
perform a multivariate analysis for
predicting complicated candy demian and
as you can see an early positive T 2mr
result was an independent predictor of
complicated condominium with an odds
ratio of thirty six point five so the
conclusions of our first study was that
a key to mr test performing patients
with proven caledonia may be a better
marker of complicated infection than
follow up blood cultures or beta glucan
assay purportedly this test may
influence the length and type of
antifungal therapy in this population
this is a picture of Madrid so come and
visit us you can see our t2 machine in
our Hospital I'm let's done move to the
second stop the second studies have
different setting completely because now
we are focused on patients who deserve
empiric antifungals apricot a fungal
therapy is a very common practice in
high-risk patients in the intensive care
unit in surgical departments and in
other departments of the hospital
however its utility has been risk
the challenge as you are aware in the in
precursor study it is very common
practice and most times blood cultures
will remain negative but the treatment
is maintained for ten or even more days
it is very difficult to stop antifungals
in a very high-risk patient once you
have a start them so in order to avoid
unnecessary prolong treatment courses
new diagnostic methods are clearly
needed non-culture based techniques and
serological biomarkers are used to stop
antipholus beta glucan is used and we
have published a paper using three
consecutive negative samples for
stopping entitlements and Lu Chi and
Brazil has published a study using two
consecutive negative beta glucans only
in an intensive care unit patients but
these strategies both the three
consecutive negatives and the two
consecutive negatives will require at
least five for seven days before you
have the results so patients will be
treated and necessarily for that period
if not more and what is the
effectiveness of using this biomarker
approach as you can see here you have
the results of my institution that were
published a couple of years ago we were
consuming as you can see here in US
dollars almost four million u.s. dollars
in antifungals in acquisition cost of
entitlements so we started our
stewardship campaigns first with
education and we save some money then we
started with our bedside advice and we
also were very successful and it
maintained the the effect is maintained
in time as you can see and it is even
improved with the use of beta glucan so
you can save money for your situation
and you
save toxicity for your patients so the
objective of this second study was to
assess the potential role of key to LR
alone or combined with those sterile oil
for biomarkers beta-d-glucose and kapha
and also with the standard cultures for
the early identification of patients
with who would have a good or a pool
evolution it was an observational
prospective pilot study with them a stop
treatment it was a pilot study the
inclusion criteria were other patients
non-pregnant non-metallic receiving
adequate empiric antifungal treatment
for less than three days according to
the IDSA guidelines for suspected
candidiasis here you have our methods
samples were collected on day zero on
day two and on day four for beta glucan
Candida albicans ham tube antibodies I
will call this test data from now on on
42 AMA our cutoff for beta glucan was
the standard one eighty our endpoint was
the value of the t two unknown or in
comparison or in combination with the
biomarkers to predict pork and what was
poor outcome for us to outcome included
either having a diagnosis of fungal
infection dying within seven days of
antifungal therapy without another
definite identifiable cost because those
patients who died early may probably
have died because of an undetected
fungal infection here you have the
hospitals that participated in this
study our hospital hospital very mignon
Hospital clinical San Carlos hospital
doctor doctor brain
Hospital Rahman Qahhar we recruited 55
out of patients with clinical suspicion
of invasive candidiasis from January to
June 2017 five patients had to be
excluded in three cases we had an
imbalance to result in one patient the
inflection was caused by Candida career
which is not detected by the t2 and what
patient did not sign the form consent so
at the end we have 49 patients here you
have the first result 35 patients had
good outcome no fungal infection all
survived and 14 patients had poor
outcome because seven died and seven had
proven invasive fungal infection the
diagnosis of invasive candidiasis
overall was then established in seven of
the 49 patients receiving empirical
treatment in an institution in which an
antifungal stewardship problem has been
working for years so even in our
institution only 14% of the patients who
receive empirical - not really need than
performers what type of infection did
this seven patients had one patient had
an esophagus perforation and Candida was
recovered from the pleura so it fulfil
the criteria of proven infection one can
you albicans pleuritis the other seven
the other six sorry were interred
dominant colonizers and the samples had
been taken in the operating room so they
were fulfilling the definition only one
of them had can you give me the
remaining seven patients died early with
no
other clear explanation so they were
considered failures as well here you
have the comparison of the clinical
characteristics of both populations the
35 with good outcome and the 14 with
poor outcome same age same sex they were
admitted most of them in the intensive
care units of our Hospital almost 80%
but the other 20% of a period treatment
is provided outside the intensive care
units as underlying diseases again
dustry testing on diseases neoplasia
cardiovascular and chronic liver disease
were the most common both populations
have three as a min charge on
comorbidity score and all of them had
plenty of reasons for receiving
empirical take from the therapy
broad-spectrum antibiotics central
catheters severe sepsis or septic shock
surgery or total parenteral nutrition as
you can see in the slide but no
differences in both populations so you
cannot say early which one really
deserves antifungal therapy regarding
type of antifungal therapy we usually
start with a kind of condoms so
practically 90% of both in populations
receive initially and a kind of condom
not many of them were previously
colonized no difference in both
populations again a huge proportion of
the patients needed mechanical
ventilation as you can see so they were
really really ill patients by definition
had received only a maximum of two or
three days of previous antifungal
therapies and look at the duration of
antifungal therapy patients with good
outcome
everything in flavor blood cultures
negative good evolution receive a mean
of 8.5 tales of antifungal therapy prop
probably not needed and patients with
poor outcome only 12% well days because
half of them died but the patients who
survived receive a much longer duration
therapy when we look at mortality early
mortality was 50% in the poor outcome by
definition and in hospital mortality was
64% in the patients with poor outcome
how did the three biomarkers perform
here you can see the results on the
captain cockta at baseline day 2 and day
4 and in blue population with good
outcome and in red poor outcome as you
can see cockta is not helpful for
separating these two populations what
about beta glucan again was not helpful
because beta-d-glucose was positive in a
very high percentage of patients in both
groups because they they are patients in
the intensive care units they receive
antimicrobials they are operated on and
they may have positive beta glucan what
about T 2 here T 2
surprise surprise was the only one which
could differentiate both populations and
most importantly the most useful test
was the baseline so you could have a
tool on day one or day two that could
help you differentiate patients who
really require antifungals and patients
in which you can stop on - once we then
analyze the sensitivity specificity
positive predictive value and negative
predictive value of the
three tests baseline day to day four and
as you can see here at the bottom of the
slide again the baseline t2 test was the
one performing best with an wonder if
perhaps combining t2 with biomarkers or
with cultures increase the results of
the test and indeed a combination of
ketone plus standard cultures do
increase the performance of the tense
because of course you may have some
species that are not detected by t2 so
you have to take into account both the
t2 and the cultures when we analyze the
area under the curve again the
combination of t2 and congressional
cultures provided the largest area under
the curve so to conclude our second
starving we believe that in patients
receiving empirical antifungal treatment
due to suspicion of the basic
candidiasis a positive t2 is associated
to a high risk of poor outcome define a
cyber proven invasive candidiasis or
early mortality so we believe that T -
amar could be a useful tool in
antifungals to worship problems let me
finish by thanking you and thanking all
the team members from my hospital the
head of the department and Mineo bolsa
medina Machado Carmen Martina myself
I thank myself Raquel Navarro Carlos
Sanchez and Antonio bueno people in
hospital clinical San Carlos Fernando
Gonzalez and Paloma Moreno in this
hospital Ramona kaha resourceful for
tuned Francesca Georgia and alien Gomez
in hospital dr. dr. Bray Jose Maria wad
oh my
memnet Francisco Lopez Medrano Mariano
sorry Jana and Hulya Oregon thank you
very much and we are ready here for your
questions thank you so much dr. Nunez
for that informative presentation and
your important research we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation window type
those questions into the box that appear
on the screen and click the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for so let's get started with our
questions from our audience we have a
great audience today our first question
is dr. Munoz would you replace the blood
culture with t2 thank you sue C know the
answer to that question is clear for me
for the time being you cannot replace
blood cultures with t2 first of all
patients may have concomitant Candida
Mia on bacteremia altitude yet may not
eat at some rare species so for the time
being we need both cultures altitude
Junius our second question from our
audience is do you see this as a
diagnostic test or a prognostic test
well this is a very good question I see
it as both it is undoubtedly a
diagnostic test it is clear and it is a
prognostic test for example in our
second study when the patients with
empiric antifungal therapy and no proven
diagnosis when the treatment was started
the early t2 that key to perform in the
first two days clearly identified a
small population which are very high
risk of dying in more than 50% on the
other hand in the candy Mia study t2
clearly identified patients with high
risk of complicated disease septic
metastasis or also dying so it is both
prognostic and a diagnostic test thank
you and I want to thank our audience for
their wonderful participation today we
have a time for a couple more questions
our next question is what would you do
differently in the patients that you
found positive why teach you in this
study
let's begin with the simple setting
patients with Candida Mia if you start
treating a patient with Candida Mia and
your first follow-up t2 is positive then
you really have to look carefully if you
have controlled all the sources if you
have drained whatever abscess or
whatever collection if you have removed
the catheters and you better go and look
the perform of endoscopy and perform
transesophageal echocardiogram because
your patient is at risk of having septic
metastasis or on in the vascular form of
candidiasis at the end a very
complicated disease if you are doing a
t2 test in a patient without approval
diagnosis yet then you really shouldn't
stop antifungals if you have a positive
t2 even if your blood cultures or your
conventional cultures of different sites
come negative because those patients
really are at high risk or of either
proven to have a fungal infection or to
die early after after the t2 is positive
thank you dr. Moniz we have time for one
more question from our audience our last
question is can this test be integrated
into stewardship absolutely I think
that's the way to go because certain
tests like this has to prove its cost
effective and should be integrated in
the fungal stewardship programs our plan
is to integrate it in impatient with
empiric therapy to decide on early a
stop of antifungals and probably perhaps
even in patients with proven infection
to determine the length of therapy so
definitely it can and should be a part
of the other formal stewardship programs
dr. Muir's thank you so much again for
your wonderful presentation
would you like to provide any closing
remarks before we close our session
today thank you Susie yeah I have to say
it has been a pleasure being able to
disseminate our small piece of research
to so many people it would be a pleasure
to see you face-to-face but I think this
way is more convenient and also to say
it has been a pleasure to do our
research with the tea to Lamar we've
found that it was a really interesting
tool for managing patients with invasive
candidiasis thank you very much for this
opportunity
I want to once again thank dr. Patricia
munos for a presentation and I'd also
like to thank
g-tube bio systems and laboratory Keene
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
it that's all for now thanks for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
bye-bye